so there's obviously nothing to
say and there's obviously no one to say
it
to and yet words
happen
spontaneously without a doer without a
controller without a
center
like leaves rustling in the
wind and it's
free it's totally
free and it's impossible to go somewhere
because it's always
it every move every word is always
it it's always already empty
without an
entity without a
path although it can appear as a
path it's free to do
so the freedom of no longer being
attached to saying
it because it's not possible to say at
every word is
it and so there's so much just joy joy
of
being
normal
ordinary
just whatever is
appearing water
drinking video
streaming simple
Ordinary
Love just nothing with
nothing joyfully
playfully
abundantly where would the sky go to be
itself
where would the wind go to be
itself where could the ocean go to get
wet so free
already it's always been this
way
it's apparently born as nothing and then
it apparently is nothing and then it
apparently passes or dies as
nothing and nothing really happened and
nothing really changed and nothing was
ever contracted and nothing was ever
expanded they may have appeared so but
that's all just a
story
there's no need for a
conceptual conversation or to
communicate
ideas although every idea or concept
that's said is still
it and yet this body continues to be
excited about
Dows and about basic needs and
freedom but no matter what
function is apparently happening in in
the body as the body it's
Freedom
yes hi in the Life chat's a beautiful
comment about crying
because being taught to play the the
game and wasting apparently 60 years
trying to win and it doesn't even
exist
yeah better to just stop playing the
game because it's already
nothing and every move is
Checkmate every move is freedom every
single move is nothing
happening there's no winning when it's
already the
prize
you've never left the
prize and there's never been an entity
there's never been a
[Music]
location there's only been that sky that
wind
although there can be an appearance of
there being a a lack
of of it of not being
it and then some sort of a path or
pointing to it that's also all it that's
also all
Freedom it's already nothing
everywhere it's already that
freedom
everywhere everything that's said every
movement that's made is already nothing
moving it's already Freedom talking
Freedom listening there's no no way to
leave
Freedom there's no way to leave
Freedom the freedom of there not being a
way to leave
Freedom there's no knowing
it there's no understand understanding
or comprehending it cuz it's
already yeah interesting comment about
never being able to play the game
correctly with neuro Divergence and all
blessing and
disguise
yeah
it's in a way it's it's really beautiful
to to not fall for the idea that I
lack and I need and I can find it in
society's
attainments a very big big
blessing
yeah yeah it just simply is as it
is and it's all Freedom already it's all
love already it's all emptiness already
empty ising
already and all these words fall short
and yet all of them are it because it
cannot be
said the freedom of it not being able to
be said and yet every word is it
yes we are so free free to pretend we
are
bound
yes free to pretend every single idea
imaginable it's impossible to not be
free it's impossible to not be nothing
and there's so much Beauty and freedom
in just being nothing which was always
the
case because there's nowhere to go
nothing to attain there can just be a
raw Beauty and
awe and
wow to just what
is without ever trying to control it or
manipulate it in order to
fulfill some
lack yeah there's no control and there's
no
problem that whole thing of bouncing
around between problems endless problems
goes
away you know you can beautifully just
hear the wind right now here in Austin
Texas you can hear it it's just so
palpable
like there's not a single entity in that
wind there's not a single idea in that
wind it's just pure innocence Pure
Freedom pure
spontaneity
and these little it's very light rain
too so there's little
[Music]
raindrops just sliding down the
window just
perfection
nothing ever had to be done for this to
be
perfect and yet there's an
appearance of lots of
salesman's of
maps and
paths and
techniques and the appearance of lots of
spiritual
Seekers that want to try to use those to
find
this what's impossible to be
missing
the freedom that it's already
Freedom the freedom that every move is
freedom the freedom that every thought
is freedom the freedom that every
appearance is
freedom the freedom that bondage is
freedom
it's not possible to leave
Freedom it's not possible to leave the
Perfection the empty unspeakable
Perfection that are these words and that
is this
listening that is this
watching that is
rubbing this facial hair and
cheek what's looking out all eyes is
empty
free
infinite
perfect without entities or locations or
names or
time it's just so pristine it's
Incorruptible uncorruptible
the uncorruptible freedom that is
already hearing this voice watching this
video speaking these words
it doesn't
require
reading any ancient
scriptures doesn't
require any meditation
it doesn't require anything because that
would be a
condition and what is being said is
unconditioned appearing as what may be
trying to find by reading a book or by
meditating
it's just unspeakably
perfect ordinary
wow there's nothing extraordinary about
it there's nothing special about
it there's no
attainment about
it there's no knowing about
it it's just already the innocence of
that
baby that dog that
cat that animal it's already that
innocence it's already that Purity and
spontaneity it's already that it's never
moved from there it's not possible to
ever
leave the Throne of
perfection
empty
still
unspeakable
holism always and
already that's cute there's
a there's a
request in the live
chat can we hear some
drumming let's see what
arises
absolutely perfect and always free the
destiny that's always
here never can move from what's always
perfect and
free always perfect and
free can't possibly move from this
Destiny everything is always
empty perfect and
free no
entity no
location no time at all just nameless
and free there's empty perfect
Destiny love
everywhere no distance no
time No
Lack empty
free
perfect
Destiny impossible to leave impossible
to leave perfect
free empty
whole
Destiny perfect free perfect and
free perfect and
free perfect and free
impossible to
leave so
good perhaps we'll come back with some
more
later thanks so much for queuing
that empty and
free perfect
impossible to
leave just what's appearing is already
whole perfect and
free
satisfied
already nowhere to go no one to be
already perfect and
free perfect and free impossible to
leave our
Destin here
already what is appearing is already
perfect perfect and
free perfect and
free
and so no one is saying it no one is
hearing
it and that can't
change so there's nothing to say there's
no one to tell there's no one to
hear and yet it can appear
like
there's someone that has some sort of
knowing and someone that lacks
the freedom that is
already it's just so free it can appear
like that it can appear like
anything
it's impossible to
leave everything is it this is it
speaking that's it listening
watching it's impossible to not be it
it's always
it it's just too simple it's too
ordinary it's just what's appearing it's
just
this this wind
this
rain this
water this
shirt that may come off at some
point
h
and there's no one doing
anything and if this
is heard by nothing which it always
is there can be that
oh well I still can attain by going to
ex
experience there'll still be something I
can get from from
that see if there's a seeing through
that that
game see if nothing can see through that
game where that appropriation comes in
and says no I can still get something
from
that I can still find Freedom in that
and it's all effortlessly morphing
towards basic needs abundance
Freedom homesteads where all of these
needs are met and there just waking
up every day just playing and being
innocent just being in
Joy the basic nourishing needs of the
body are
met and then we can have as much wild
sex and Loud [__] music and
comedy and whatever the [__]
whatever all kinds of yummy yummy yummy
yummy
foods all kinds of beautifully new
futuristic
engineering
yeah this is already
so perfect and
free and there's an apparent
appropriation no it's not it's not that
I'll get
it and there's a big limit
there the limit
is I will be perfect and free I will
become it after that after that
experience after X whatever it
is it's such a big
limit I'm not and I will be after
X but that's the Limitless appearing to
limit itself with
that Pursuit for the freedom it already
is
[Music]
oh
yeah in the comments I want to go
streaking yeah
absolutely the freedom of being
naked this is already so
naked this is already without
anything the freedom can appear as
streaking it can appear as shame of
showing
[Music]
genitals I'm so worried about people
others seeing my pee
[Music]
PE my
vagina I'm so
shameful it's just Freedom appearing as
that the dog the cat the
baby naked no
clothes it's not possible to attain the
nakedness
the nakedness is
already everything's already
naked there's already no one home
anywhere it's already just the
wind it's already the
wind
no
conclusion
will
land at Perfection and
freedom not even that perfection freedom
is already for No One not even that no
conclusion
none no
box no
bound it's not another
ground a bound is just another
ground and there is no ground
no ground never been a ground and never
will be a
ground although it can appear as a
ground so
free empty words just empty empty empty
words empty empty
words empty hearing empty
watching
freedom
freedom freedom
freedom always Already Free as
[__]
always
already free ass
[__] always Already Free as [__] always
already uhuh free as [__] uh uh uh
always Already Free as [__] uh uh uh
always and already free as
[__]
impossible to leave what you already are
[__] impossible to leave what
you already are [__] impossible
to leave what you already are
[__] impossible to leave what
you all read
are impossible to leave what you already
are [__] impossible to leave
what you already are [__]
impossible to leave what you already are
[__] can't leave the freedom
that is already can't leave the
emptiness that is
already can't leave the fact that
there's no one home already can't leave
the fact that there's no one home
already can't leave the fact that
there's no one home
already
can't leave the fact that there's no one
home
already so simple funny and ordinary
haha not a teaching not a concept not a
knowing not an understanding it's what
already is it's what already
is it's what already
is no
knowing no
understanding no
concept it's what already
is and it can appear like an obsession
with knowing an obsession with
understanding an obsession with
Concept I have so many Concepts and
they're so intelligent and you should
listen to me Teach You Concepts all day
long yeah listen to me Teach You
Concepts all day
long listen to me Teach You Concepts all
day
[Music]
long
no
thanks because it's always already free
ass [__] [__] always and already
free as [__] [__] always and
already free as [__] [__] always
and already free of [__]
[__] always always them already
free as [__] [__] always Already
Free as [__] [__] Already Free
as [__] [__] [__] free free free
free free free free free free
[Music]
free freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom yeah freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom yeah
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom yeah freedom freedom
yeah freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom yeah freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom yeah freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom yeah
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom yeah freedom freedom
yeah freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom yeah freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom yeah freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom yeah
freedom is already here it's right now
yeah freedom is already here it's right
now yeah freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom yeah freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom is
already here yeah freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
yeah freedom is already here always
always and forever yeah freedom is
already here always and forever yeah
freedom is already here always and
forever yeah freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom yeah
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom yeah freedom is already
here [__] always yeah freedom is
already here [__] always yeah
freedom freedom freedom freedom Purity
and innocence freedom freedom freedom
freedom Purity and innocence freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom yeah freedom freedom freedom
freedom
yeah yes [__] freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom yeah yes
[__] freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom yeah yes [__] freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom yeah freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom
[Music]
yeah
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom yeah
freedom freedom yeah freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
yeah
freom
yeah freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom yeah freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom yeah uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh
uh uh uh uh uh
uh so
simple never left it never left it never
left it never left it never left it
can't leave it can't leave it can't
leave it can't leave it never left it
never can leave it yeah never can never
can never can leave it yeah never left
it never left it never left it never
left it never left it can't leave it
can't leave this Freedom [__] can't
leave it can't leave it can't leave this
Freedom [__] can't leave it can't leave
it can't leave this Freedom [__] to
free too free to free maybe can up to
leave it but never actually leave
it s free it can appear like you leave
it but you can't believe
it so free oh I've left
it no you haven't never
[Laughter]
can
oh
just the ordinariness of what's
appearing
how can one leave the ordinariness of
what's
appearing or how can one leave what's
appearing impossible to leave what's
appearing
for
oh
I so
good
I'm so
grateful for the fam in the live
chat
[Music]
meow
yeah
woof
as long as there is looking for
something to
attain there's the appearance of
mutually assured
destruction
there's a question in the chat about if
there are dreams and what are they like
yeah there are dreams and there are just
dreams
I was gonna say there their dreams
filled with gold filled
with
fireworks filled with the most lavish
luxuries
imaginable and I finally found wholeness
in those
dreams
oh just simple and ordinary
dreams [__] your
mother
that was her on the mic a moment
ago bulging
clitoris
Je
I can't just say that dreaming about a
[__] your mother but got to [__] your
father too got to get in that that booty
hole of Papa
too gotta take Papa's dick
too
it's pretty uh pretty
big hit the gag
reflex
well before the stream continues where
there's a continued discussion about
[__] all of the mothers and
fathers
oh uh can't exclude uh grandmothers and
grandfathers also yes they need the dick
too [__] it everyone needs the dick
um what are those called those massive
acoustic chambers that are
like uh 360° acoustic
Chambers except in place of where every
single one of those speakers is is
either a
clitoris or a
[__] and so the whole thing is just
like like licking
clitorises
or sucking the
[__] imagine those kinds of
um inquiries to the um presidents of
nation
states so uh what's the what's the girth
down there
president how's the how's the wife's
[__] How is how's it going have you
have you tried anal yet how is it pretty
good I have any threes sus
recently what if uh what if I took a
took a stab at at your husband's back
door that' be
okay what if I was to try to fulfill the
wife or what if the presidents of the
nation
states banging it
out what if uh we
had these the presidents of nation
states just ramming each other
online just watching them Ram each other
just give each other the
D
oh all of a sudden so
much relaxation of those tight ass
buttholes
[Music]
a
okay so free it can appear like
whatever nowhere to
go thanks for tuning
in
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom yeah freedom freedom
yeah freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom yeah Purity and
innocence already yeah Purity and
innocence already yeah freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
yeah freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom freedom yeah impossible
to leave this Freedom this Freedom yeah
impossible to leave impossible to leave
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom freedom yeah always always
already freedom freedom freedom freedom
Yahoo
freom Freedom
yeah